there are debt-free screams and then
there are debt free scream and these
guys right here are amazing Amir and
Connie are with us from Atlanta Georgia
if you are watching the video channel
and you have seen Chris Hogan's everyday
millionaires book trailer you've seen
Connie in there she's featured in that
as one of the real everyday millionaires
and so this is a great story I can't I
know a little of the story but I can't
wait to to go through it let's do the
normal thing how much debt have you paid
off well we I'll go over the numbers
here we have paid off nine hundred and
eighty four thousand dollars okay that's
all right did this take it take us ten
years okay and are your range of income
during that time the range of income
started with about a hundred and sixty
five thousand and gradually kinda went
up to about three hundred and about two
years ago we started our own practice we
are the gun out group and this year we
will bring in over a million dollars Wow
you're not just every day millionaire
you're earning a million as Wow
yes well I know how you paid off the 984
now I'm income so you Doc's you're
doctors no no no you said you start your
own practice so well it's basically we
are a leadership development company we
guide leaders to create extraordinary
cultures that deliver breakthrough
results an unprecedented fulfillment
apparently that's what we do I do the
easy part I get on stage and speak and
do consulting and these guys do all the
hard stuff behind the scene okay very
cool and these guys - you're right the
kiddos I guess that's right Nassim and
Naveed okay they've been with us
throughout this entire journey this is
your son and daughter that's right now
son and daughter okay Connie has been
the main engine behind this she sort of
dragged me into it I kicked and screamed
and eventually became a believer
Charlotte she's the main engine so
Connie what got all this started
what got all this started was I was
looking at TLC and I saw this reality
show with a couple that had a large
number of kids and they had a
question-and-answer section and that
someone asked him how can you afford all
these kids and they said they were dead
free I'm going like looked at a mere
like they're dead free we couldn't eat
that free we have two kids I went to see
what what they did and found out what
the program they used it was very
biblical but not practical enough for me
and just one day I was driving down the
highway in Atlanta and there you were on
a billboard mm-hmm I looked you up
discovered the class there was one
happening like within a three days that
I've found you out and told Amir we have
to do it so signed us up for FPU and its
history from there so 10 years ago you
went through SPU yes yes and then you've
out there so that 984 that's mortgages
and everything ah yeah actually very
quickly we paid off a little bit of debt
that we had on it was just a little bit
of student loans
for these guys and a credit card so
about $16,000 but the house has been
sort of the albatross we bought this
house before we met you and then we try
to say oh geez what did we get ourselves
into but we were upside down we said
okay well you know what we're just gonna
use our house to be a blessing to other
people hold the glasses and all that but
we were kind of stuck with it and on
September 17th we were able to write
that check and and make it all happen
okay Wow yeah pletely
so Connie this is all your fault yes it
is so what do you tell people the secret
to getting out of that is the secret to
getting out of debt I would say is
definitely being on the same page and
sticking with it it was ten years yeah
you have to stick with that goal my goal
was to be right here where I am today
mm-hmm to do this debt-free screen
mm-hmm so looking at that and watching
you online thank God for YouTube now
you're being was really great it really
made a difference and the one thing that
I don't know what you say on radio that
you say before the debt free screams of
you but you said that you say it every
time you said believe that it can happen
it does happen every day in America
mm-hmm that phrase always brought tears
to my eyes because I believe that it
could happen and it did happen for us
and it can happen for anybody who puts
these steps and the weird thing is um
did not go bananas until you were deaf
right this year yeah time you went that
free and about the time you you a good
income above way above average income
obviously but I mean it's gone nuts now
I mean you're just like ching-ching
right yeah it's awesome but I mean all
it's weird that that that that isn't
what dead end what did it was the
perseverance yes and pushing through and
pushing through and pushing through and
so the house is worth what the houses
still has not recovered from the
downturn and whatnot so it's probably
worth about six hundred and fifty
thousand now
and you've got other you got like 401k
money in that customer over a million
dollar net worth yes so in that sense
we're doing it one thing I wanted to add
Dave is that shortly after we went
through FPU I was managing a plant and
our results were I found myself in a
situation where our results were really
terrible and we wanted to really make a
difference in terms of our results and
Connie and I basically brought FPU to
the to the plant because we figured the
best way to actually sustainably grow
our results is to help people with their
finances with their health with
relationships you know I would do
marriage counseling I've been training
in that at all I was faking it totally
but it was working and we brought FPU at
7:30 in the morning on Saturdays we
would do this it was at that time
thirteen weeks we did it four times in
fact these guys the first time they were
exposed to it because we had a Dave
Ramsey clause in our will okay you guys
are gonna be exposed to this so we
dragged them to this course at 7:30 in
the morning on Saturdays and essentially
what this did for us at the plant was it
really transformed a lot of lives and
since then we have coordinated thirteen
classes we just finished one couple of
weeks ago really helped us how old are
the kids now okay and they are well
established in this methodology and in
fact you know if I could I just want to
share something they're also debt-free
with the exception of their mortgage
there is you know we don't have any
secrets they've been right there with us
but there's one thing that we've kept
from them and I'd like you me up
something for this it was a little
secret let's just keep it secret is just
because they're here and they're gonna
scream that free with us we would like
them to know that their mortgages are
paid off
[Applause]
[Applause]
you know we're really clear that the
best thing that we can leave to kids is
the wisdom to know how to handle their
lives and and you guys are changing your
family tree big time they have proven to
us
they're so much you know they're better
people than I will ever be and and I
look up to them they're my coaches they
have their finances together and
everything else in their life so we
figured you know what we want to get
them off to a great start they're both
owned homes and now you guys just
witness the whole thing listening and
watching on YouTube went from in debt a
million dollars to being millionaires to
the change of the family tree paying off
their kids mortgages right here live on
the air
[Applause]
four of you counted down you're all for
doing a debt-free stream a mere Conde de
vide in the seam Wow
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two one
I think we just set a record oh it's
beautiful
this is the Dave Ramsey show
[Music]